it's definitely gonna be a darker one
darker than what we've seen before in
the past fast eight is gearing up for
release in April 2017 and no one is more
excited than star Michelle Rodriguez
we're gonna go hard on this one and
charlisse their own is I think the most
powerful villain this franchise has ever
seen what is it like working opposite
her are we gonna see more girl power we
got to work with her for a couple of
days and I'll tell you if there's
anything that I have to say in order for
me to be a part of the franchise in the
future they need to up the ante on the
females I mean it's like a sausage
factory in this thing and I just need
some more feminine energy what you boys
never saw a girl in a dress before
but before fast eight hits theaters
Michelle is starring in a family drama
called Milton secret walking decks was
office I know the essential theme in
this film that was very touching and
moving is obviously bullying I know
you're very passionate about speaking
out about it why is that so important to
you a punch in the face is a social
media post and it's a suicide I don't
understand I'm more sensitive now
because I've always been a very
tomboyish very Jersey City aw shucks
what's a kind of woman you know I just
never gave up about you know words now I
understand that I have to respect words
and words are powerful and they are
dangerous and and they hurt people
Milton secret is in select theaters and
on-demand and digital HD on September
30th